from the slums of Shaolin Wu-Tang Clan
strikes again the Rissa the gista old
dirty bastard inspector deck Raekwon the
chef you guard Ghost Face Killer
m-e-t-h-o-d man
m-e-t-h-o-d man hey you get off My Cloud
you don't know me and you don't know my
steps
just
[Music]
Sonny's contract is mad things
give me five years of your life
here
just wrote this right now yes son
what you thought I was doing on the roof
the whole time not supposed to go on the
roof he keeps riding like this
you can climb to the top of the Empire
State Building oh yo this
it's hot son King
Kongs in your head like a nurse
[Music]
come fully packed with the fat Rocky
stack shame on you when you step through
to the old dirty bastard straight from
the Brooklyn Zoo and I'll be damned if I
let any man come through my Center you
enter the winter straight up and down
that is packed Jam you can't slim
don't let me get home
[Music]
get it down
it's about time
about time yo I was waiting for this
be quiet out loud my style is wow so
Booky
how long that this rhyme took me ejected
styles for my lead through weapon my pen
that rocks from here to Oregon here's
more again catch it like a psycho
flashback I love cats and rappers a gun
you wouldn't bust back I come with
in all types of shapes and sounds and
where I lounges my stomping grounds I
give water to my peeps across the water
to go and snatch up props all around the
border and get far like a shooting star
cause who our heart is dimming a light a
Pablo Escobar point blank as I kick the
Square Biz There It Is We're pros and it
goes
[Applause]
not easy
with the feedback block you don't need
that a center clock hoe where the
is y'all see that feeling mad hostel
wearing Aeropostale flowing like Christ
when I speaks the gospel stroll with the
Holy roll then attack the globe with the
buckets South the Ruckus 10 tops to men
committing massive turn the other cheek
and I'll break your slaying boom
bangs like African drugs coming around
the mountain when I come crazy
[Music]
I need to chill out
what you think
I think
I think we getting this pressed up
tomorrow all right
first of all who's your A and R mountain
climber who plays in electric guitar why
he don't know the meaning of dope when
he's looking for a suit and tired rap
that's cleaning in a bar soap and I'm
the dirtiest thing in sight matter of
fact bring out the girls and let's have
a mud fight
foreign
[Music]
everybody
check this out all right
[Music]
he's a hook or something you know what
I'm saying oh protection that can't have
no hook but this shit's different I'm
feeling like this actually needs us
there's some uh some melodic for
this you know what I'm saying
survival
yeah
[Music]
cash rules
cash rules everything around me cream
get the money dollar dollar bill y'all
get the money dollar dollar bills y'all
cash rules everything around me cream
cash Foods everything around me cream
get the money dollar dollar bill y'all
oh
[Music]
Elektra is owned by Warner Brothers
Warner Brothers is a publicly traded
company
all right so look boom
we still got Def Jam on the table right
yeah but you know they can also pull
they offer too
we have to make a decision
cash rules everything around me cream
get the money dollar dollar bills yeah
hey
think carefully Rizzo
you don't want to play yourself or maybe
you already have
damn
200k
down the gutter
that ain't no short money player
not at all
you've only saying that cause
I got no strategy
no vision
I'm too scared to play the game
checkmate
all right
you may have beat me
but did you really win sellout yo oh
ah yo
I don't really know how to play
can you teach me
all right so
when you start a game
never win a show Fear
ever
the way you start determines how you
finish you wanna
step into your bravery
even if that means being scared
you gotta think about the future
we
want Wu-Tang
to be forever
you get it
I think so
what do I do next
[Music]
um
what's up man
hey
we just signed it loud
well you just what
[Music]